this is a recipe for cold udon it uses
eggplant and tomato so it's more like
summer I love it fun and it's so good so
in the summer time in Japan it's very
humid and it's super hot so this is the
perfect dish for the kind of summer
[Music]
[Applause]
that ballsy uses it's meant to you meant
to you eat soy sauce paste with dashi
and it's a kind of dipping sauce you can
use it for a lot of dishes like salmon
and dipping sauce for tempura man means
noodle and to you it's dipping sauce
this concentrated pre-made sauce is used
mainly for like various different kind
of noodle dishes
[Music]
[Applause]
you can make it from scratch but it's
very easy to find in a grocery store and
I think you can find it in an Asian
grocery story in the US if you want to
make it from scratch you can make it
with dashi and soy sauce and meaning but
if you use meant to you you can make
good on on a whim
[Music]
the last time I made Rudolfo a video it
was beef udon and it's a narrow Dom but
this one is different because it's for
summer build on so this is different
because it's now served hot and uses
different ingredients like summer
vegetable
[Music]
like yakisoba you can experiment with it
maybe you can make Italian Oh Dom I've
seen carbonara
you don't before we're always like a
blank canvas so experiment with that and
experiment with your favorite flavors
and ingredients and make your own food
on
[Music]